[Music]
hi we are here with Hy today thank you
so much for joining us to talk about
your music and your BD businesses thank
you for having me you are an
award-winning musician a Grammy nominee
walk me through what it was like to
realize that you could sing and act at a
young age oh my goodness I remember the
first time someone ever told me that I
had a nice voice I was in like in the
car I was singing along to probably an a
LaVine song on the radio and my mom
turned to my father and said Chris
listen to her and my dad was like what
she was like she's good and I just
remember you know the way that felt and
how proud I felt in that moment I think
that's one of those memories that kind
of like stays with you especially when
it ends up becoming you know part of
your line of work and after high school
I intended to go to uh like a pretty a
claimed University City and found out
that I could not afford to go which was
something I knew it wasn't a surprise to
me that my parents you know didn't have
a lot of money at all but being 17 I
couldn't really apply for loans or I
couldn't really take matters into my own
hands and I was really frustrated
because everyone had told me my whole
life you know if you take these classes
you get good grades you do these things
you go to a good college etc etc and
that was like life kind of hitting me in
the face of like it doesn't go that way
sometimes and that was my big moment of
like well what do you mean I did
everything right and so from that moment
forward I was just like oh I'm just
going to do everything wrong cuz doing
everything right doesn't matter so I
moved to New York I didn't go to college
at all and then I started making music
and I just sort of never looked
back so being an entrepreneur you you
know obviously have your musical career
and your musical brand but you also
ventured into other avenues of
entrepreneurialism you have a beauty
brand now about face and a94 walk me
through your decision to enter the
beauty space specifically I started
doing my own makeup most out of
necessity my first record company was a
boutique label and their whole roster
was DJs was like male electronic artists
so that initial conversation was really
funny when it started becoming like yeah
I need styling I need Glam I need this
and they were like you have $20 the guy
the other guys are showing up with the
USB and like the hoodie and doing the
thing and that was like a moment where I
realized I didn't have access to the
same resources as some of my other peers
especially my female or like female
presenting peers and so I was like okay
well I'm not going
to fall behind I just need
to figure out how to do it myself I had
a real motivation to make
products quite frankly that would just
work for me that I couldn't find on the
market so with that being said I was
actually approached by the founders of
hard candy which was one of my favorite
makeup brands ever as a kid and we just
felt like the perfect
pairing my last question I have for you
is what is next for you do you have any
big plans with the beauty brands with
other entrepreneurial adventures with
your music I would love to know what
you're looking forward to in the next
couple of months or year oh my gosh let
me tell you I am doing a lot of things
right now I'm definitely working on
music but I'm kind of always working on
music and you know about face has a ton
of really really exciting launches
coming in the next year and some retail
expansion same for
a94 I'm raising my son which is amazing
he uh just turned two a couple months
ago so I'm navigating that yeah really I
think just trying to continue all the
amazing projects that I have going right
now and integrating all that into into
motherhood and enjoying the last year of
my 20s yes you know I got one year left
until I start the big 30 I started doing
this when I was 18 I felt so old at the
time and I've been doing it for over a
decade now so sometimes I just feel
ancient and I've realized I think this
past year just how young I really am and
that I have such a long runway in front
of me to try new things and explore
different things and uh I'm going to try
them
[Music]
all